ja meine damen und herren sie wenn es
vielleicht im laufe des vormittags schon
mitbekommen haben unser reporter paul
ronzheimer ist heute morgen in kabul
gelandet mittendrin im chaos auf dem
flughafen hat uns von dramatischen
szenen berichtet aus erster hand und wir
freuen uns dass wolfgang kubicki der
stellvertretende fdp-vorsitzende
weiterhin bei uns ist um auch über
dieses thema zu sprechen
herr kubicki bevor wir über versagen der
bundesregierung und so weiter sprechen
was bekommen sie an informationen über
die situation
zunächst einmal steht fest dass inhalte
nächsten 48 stunden die über
bildungsmaßnahmen eingestellt werden die
deutschen soldaten zurückgeholt werden
das machen nicht nur wir das machen wir
unsere europäischen partner weil die
amerikaner ihrerseits bereits damit
beginnen sozusagen das schutzschild um
den militärischen teil des flughafens
abzubauen müssen wir bis zum 31 bis zum
31 august draußen sein
wir wissen dass man mehrere hundert
deutsche sich in afghanistan aufhalten
die wir teilweise momentan gar nicht
erreichen können und wir wissen dass wir
circa 6.000 ortskräfte plus war also
inklusive familien nicht mehr aus
afghanistan raus bekommen können dass
etwas was seit sonntag habe ich mich
noch nie so sehr für mein land geschehen
wie jetzt das wiki was denn jemand weiß
niemals geplant dass die ortskräfte raus
kann also waren wir jemals gut genug
vorbereitet weil die regierung niemals
gut genug vorbereitet die deutschen
rauszuholen wir sind ja mittlerweile uns
alle einig dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss in der nächsten
legislaturperiode muss nicht jetzt
sondern mit 99 deutschen bundestag weil
wir auf vielerlei ebenen ein wirkliches
versagen von staatlichen organen von
ministerien feststellen können und es
gar nicht weiter hilft jetzt nicht
wechselseitig die schuld zuzuschieben
aber noch im mai hat das auswärtige amt
in mehreren ausschüssen des deutschen
bundestages erklärt dass man die
ortskräfte doch lieber in afghanistan
lassen sollte statt sich herauszuholen
vielleicht auch in der annahme dass es
vielleicht doch noch länger dauern würde
aber ein war klar wer kurz oder lang
werden die taliban die macht in
afghanistan übernehmen und dann wäre es
notwendig gewesen nicht nur moralisch
noch rechtlich wie haben die menschen in
gefahr gebracht notwendig gewesen sich
darauf vorzubereiten sie in der zeit die
wir nur an barry rauszuholen jacobi
entwickelt diese da situation ist auch
wirklich ganz schrecklich man muss sich
das wirklich mal vorstellen da gibt es
deutsche also mit einem deutschen pass
besitzen dort und dann wird gesagt jetzt
ist es vorbei wie kann man denen jetzt
noch helfen was ist ihr vorschlag
wir kriegen eine ganze reihe von
hilferufen mich selbst auch nicht rufen
leute an die ganze hier in deutschland
die verband in afghanistan damit diese
kontakte haben die wirklich auch völlig
verzweifelt sind weil die überlegungen
wir reden jetzt mit den taliban und
hoffen dass sie die grenzen aufmachen so
dass die menschen über den landweg
herausgebracht werden können relativ
illusorisch ist ich meine ist doch ein
treppenwitz der geschichte ist aber was
sagen dagegen dass wir jetzt die ihre
hanna bitten müssen also die mullahs in
teheran die wir gerade mit sanktionen
belegt da wir bitten müssen dass sie
ihrerseits helfen sollen
zunächst einmal kann man den menschen
beraten sich jetzt in sicherheitsmann
sich zu sich zu verstecken dass sie
nicht nicht aufgefunden werden und dann
muss alles was wir machen können europas
die europäer machen können notfalls auch
mit viel geld als relativ egal
die zahl der ddr auch gemacht haben wir
auch menschen frei gekauft und das
müssen wir die leute die wir beschäftigt
hat für die verpflichtung freikaufen und
dann muss man jetzt verhandlungen führen
ich bin froh dass jedenfalls in doha der
ehemalige deutsche botschafter in kabul
jetzt hat die gespräche mit ich möchte
noch mal ganz kurz ganz klar festhalten
sie haben gesagt innerhalb von 48
stunden wir haben bis heute die
information gehabt am wochenende das
erste gold das heißt vor dem wochenende
sind die deutschen raus die bundeswehr
ja werden die wetten dass maßnahmen
jedenfalls eingestellt
wir haben diese diese diese öffentlichen
erklärungen auch um panik zu vermeiden
aber die menschen sind bereits in panik
muss ich die bilder vom flughafen in
kabul nur ansehen die taliban lassen
überhaupt niemand mehr zum flughafen und
die menschen jetzt vor dem flughafen
stehen die lassen wir dann anschließend
die hände der taliban fallen stadt die
jetzt alle da sind raus zu und dann wenn
sie draußen sind zu sortieren so gehören
sie eigentlich hin nicht haben sie
erfüllen die kriterien die wir
vorgeschlagen haben jeder mensch der
jetzt bleiben muss und dann an leib und
leben gefährdet ist der geht auf unser
ticket dir geht noch in westdeutschland
[Musik]